actually thank you actually before I get
to the limits of liberalism my lectures
are lagging behind the titles for
reasons too tedious to recount I'll talk
I'll get on the Christianity fowl if
that if you remember I didn't get round
two last time so there first of all with
Christianity fowl you know then anybody
who wants to leave and disgust can do
that and then but if they do they'll
miss the second bit of the show which is
the limits of liberalism all right
the account of Christian faith that I
gave last time is one that I take to be
thoroughly scriptural Orthodox and
traditional with nothing newfangled
about it and in no sense a sort of
coterie minded interpretation indeed as
you would have noticed I'm sure a lot of
it runs back at least as far as Thomas
Aquinas and I think that the account
right or wrong I mean if that's what
Christianity is roughly about or
something like that is for one thing a
lot more realistic than the likes of
Richard Dawkins I mean it takes the full
measure I think of human perversity and
depravity in contrast and
extraordinarily Pangloss Ian's view of
humanity of Dawkins is The God Delusion
at the same time on the other hand it's
a good deal more audacious than the
liberal humanists and the rationalists
about how this dire condition is to be
repaired it's a once so is at once as it
were on the one hand immense
immeasurably more more gloomy in its
view of the human species than the
beyond consol liberal intelligentsia
only I think Freud or the philosophy of
Arthur Schopenhauer can match its
unremitting gloom which I believe is no
more than realism Schopenhauer possibly
the most gloomy philosopher who ever
lived so utterly an incan remorselessly
glum that he's unwittingly of areas
that's right I don't know why there's
something funny about unremitting gloom
but there isn't and certainly a good
deal more coal died than the callow
upbeat nurse of much American ideology
this is another of my little liberal
intervention isms which tends I think
the mistake a kind of hubristic can do
er II for hope very very different
things
this view believes that a good deal of
human wickedness is of course
historically caused and conditioned and
can be changed or at least ameliorated
by political action but it also believes
that it's wildly implausible given the
scale and persistence and tenacity of
human wickedness to think that this is
all there is to the matter at the same
time however it's absurdly and
outrageously more hopeful the liberal
rationalism as well as absurdly more
gloomy with its apparently unhinged
belief I mean the apparently unhinged
Christian belief the demented Christian
belief you might even say that not only
is the salvation of the human species
possible but that contrary to all we
read in the newspapers or see on Fox
Television it has in some sense already
taken place not even the wildest utopian
secularists were assert something as
outrageous as that a huge number of the
charges that Dickens levels against
actually existing religion so to speak
seemed to me as I think I said last time
thoroughly justified and he deserves
ditch khun's both of them deserves a
great deal of credit for parading them
so forcefully whatever slight air of
monomania might lurk around the edges
indeed it's hard to imagine isn't it how
any polemic against say the clerical
abuse of children or the religious
degradation of women could be too severe
or hyperbolic yet it's scarcely a novel
point is it that for the most part
Dickens
tends to hold forth on religion in truly
shocking ignorance of many of its
tenants a situation I've compared
elsewhere with the arrogance of one who
regards himself as competent to
pronounce on arcane questions of biology
having on the strength of a passing
acquaintance with the British book of
birds or if you like the book of British
Birds and some might claim the ditch
Keynes is speaking of religion as a
social phenomenon not of theology this
is fair enough but how could you speak
of say fascism as a social phenomenon
without a reasonably accurate grasp of
its doctrine as Dennis Turner writes it
is indeed extraordinary how
theologically stuck in their ways some
atheists are indeed Stephen Mulhall the
philosophy English lost the rights of
the atheist superstitious conception of
God superstitious conception of God an
atheist who has more than a primitive
which is usually to say satanic
understanding of theology is in my view
as rare as an American who hasn't been
abducted by aliens great many secular
intellectuals with a reasonably
sophisticated sense of what goes on in
academic many academic areas other than
their own doubt an abysmal accrued and
infantile version of what theology has
traditionally maintained and are quite
complacently happy to do so they claim
for example as Christian doctrines very
confidently such flagrant falsehoods as
the idea that God is some kind of super
entity outside the universe or that he
created the world rather as a carpenter
might fashion a chair but faith in this
God means above all and firstly
subscribing to the proposition that he
exists they call last time the yeti view
of faith that there is a real me inside
me call the soul which is truly me as
the body isn't and which a wrathful God
may consign to hell if I'm not well
behaved that are uttered
Endon see on this deity is what stops us
thinking and acting for ourselves that
this God cares deeply about whether
we're sinful or not because if we are he
demands to be placated and other such
secularist fantasies Daniel Dennett
defines religion at the beginning of his
rather dreary book breaking the spell an
original book heading as I quote social
systems whose participants avow belief
in a supernatural agent or agents whose
approval is to be sought unquote which
as far as Christianity goes is rather
like beginning a history of the potato
by defining it as a rare species of
rattlesnake with boring predictability
Dennett's
God is a satanic God when people like
this are informed that none of these are
Orthodox Christian beliefs they imagine
that this means not that they never were
but they've been hastily ditched in the
modern age by a clutch of guitar toting
liberal revisionists and indeed it's
logical enough isn't it that those who
see religion as nothing but false
consciousness should so often get its
beliefs so wrong I mean so childishly
wrong since what profit is to be yielded
by the patient inspection of a belief
system which you hold to be as
pernicious as it's foolish who is likely
to launch a time-consuming investigation
of what Cabalists or occultists or
Rosicrucians actually hold when they're
still priests
and Clarissa to be read and the children
to be put to bed so it is that as it was
logical in some sense of those who pull
em enacted politicize most ferociously
against religion are often those least
qualified to do so for the most
luminously understandable of reasons
namely they don't think it's evil worth
getting to understand or that there's
anything substantial there to understand
or argue it it's as though when it comes
to religion I mean that's to say the
single most astonishingly powerful
pervasive tenacious and enduring form
of popular culture but history has ever
witnessed as well as in many respects as
Dickens is quite right to point out one
of the most obnoxious when it comes to
that any shoddy old travesty will do and
this quite often from those who are most
of boolean tea on the side of the common
people in a similar way when it comes to
the political left very often no blow is
too low no libel too crass no slur to
scabrous a certain of its opponents
among whom were now forced to include
the more Bibulus half of ditch khun's
you're supposed to laugh at that
engineering and vote doesn't matter and
when it comes to god liberal rationalist
who are otherwise accustomed to
enforcing fine discriminations are
committed agreeably enough quite often
to be a sloppy and raucous as they
please in the face of so-called
irrationalism science leads to stridency
with hardly a struggle like a so-called
war on terror such rationalism is then
in danger of mimicking the very
irrationalism so-called it confronts in
a very act of seeking to resist it yet
this straw targeting of christianity is
now really commonplace among academics
and intellectuals I say academics are
intellectuals because in a certain sense
I think intellectuals are the reverse of
academics the very opposite of academics
but that's another lecture I'll give you
for a small fee in private if you ask me
that's to say among those who wouldn't
allow a first-year student to get away
with the gross caricatures in which they
themselves indulge with such reckless
insouciance dictions on theology is
rather like someone who lays claim to
the title of literary critic by
asserting that there are some very nice
bits in the novel and some scary bits as
well but it's all very sad in the end
however it is of course most certainly
Christianity and not liberal rationalism
which is largely responsible for this
intellectual indolence for a part from
the signal instance of Stalinism it's
hard to think of a historical movement
which has Moore's quality betrayed its
own revolutionary origins Christianity
long ago as we know shifted from the
side of the poor and dispossessed to
that of the rich and aggressive the
liberal establishment really has nothing
whatsoever to fear from it and indeed a
great deal to gain for the most part
it's become the Creed of the suburban
well-to-do as we know not the
astonishing promise offered to the
riffraff and undercover anti imperialist
militants with whom Jesus himself hung
out these people's responds to the
anawim a biblical term which can be
roughly translated into American English
as loser
is by and large to flush them off the
streets this brand of piety is horrified
by the sight of a female breast but
considerably less appalled by the
obscene inequalities between rich and
poor not least rich and poor nations it
laments the death of a fetus but is
apparently undisturbed by the burning to
death of children in Iraq or Afghanistan
in the name of American global Dominion
by and large it worships a God fashioned
blasphemously in its own image a clean
shaven short-haired gun-toting sexually
obsessed God with a special regard for
that ontological II privileged piece of
a globe just south of Canada and just
north of Mexico rather than the Yahweh
who is homeless faceless stateless and
imageless who prompts his people out of
their comfortable settlement into the
trackless terrors of the desert and who
brusquely informs them that their burnt
offerings stink in his nostrils far from
refusing to conform to the powers of
this world
as we know has become the nauseating
camp of lying politicians corrupt
bankers and fanatical neo-cons
as well as an immensely profitable
industry in its own right probably no
nation on earth has plucked from a New
Testament such a farrago
of superstitious nonsense than the
United States with its incurable talent
for going over the top
such religion is oily sanctimonious
brutally oppressive and violently
bigoted morality in its eyes is a matter
of the bedroom rather than the boardroom
it regards negativity as a thought crime
views pessimism as unpatriotic and
imagines that being a Christian means
maintaining a glazed grin a substantial
bank balance and a mouth full of pious
platitudes it announces terrorism but
excludes from its strictures such
kidnapping torturing murdering outfits
as the CIA one CIA crime by the way
which hasn't received the urgent
attention it should I think was the
agency's dissemination of a Russian
translation of TS Eliot's the wasteland
during the Cold War
was this to demonstrate the virtues of
free verse and free expression or too
demoralized Soviets by unleashing the
virus of nihilism
I'll skate guru ver this faith of the
Pharisees can't see that the only cure
for terrorism though it may be too late
but the only cure for terrorism is
justice or grasp as I was saying last
time how much the hideous and polluted
and disfigured thing on its own
threshold the roaring and raging fury at
its gates is among other things its own
monstrous creation it's unable to
acknowledge this thing of Darkness as
its own unable to find its own
reflection in this distorted image which
will be the essential condition of what
christianity has traditionally known as
repentance in the light of this
catastrophic situation the bellicose
ravings of Dickens are if anything too
muted it is hard to avoid the feeling
that a God as bright resourceful and
imaginative as the one we might just
possibly have couldn't have hit on sold
some more agreeable way of saving the
world than religion and talking then
about the distinction between what seems
to be a scriptural and an ideological
kind of Christian faith and as far as
that distinction goes we just I suppose
have to interminably argue argue it and
I suppose that part of that exercise is
what Nietzsche who held that churches
were the tombs and Sepulchre of God
called in an allusion to King Guard
saving Christianity from christened 'im
it's not a project I think that holds
out much hope of success any form of
Christian faith which fails to
constitute a scandal and affront to the
political state is in my view
effectively worthless of course it's
from standpoint of values rooted among
other places in the judeo-christian
heritage that we identify these failings
in the church just as liberal
civilization is as it were its own
imminent critique as a culture which
never ceases to castigate its own
shortcomings
reference to its own commendably high
standards even so it might be objected
in what might be called the populist
argument from the person in the pew the
account of Christian faith I've outlined
is the product of an intellectual elite
lawfully removed from actually existing
religion and of course it's true that
there's a gap between a sophisticated
theological understanding or scholarly
understanding of Christian gospel and
the faith of millions of men and women
who have neither the leisure or the
education for such scholarly inquiries
much the same gap however yawns between
say Dawkins and your average believer in
evolution I mean I come from a country
where they do believe in evolution
actually or between Islamic theology and
those diluted Islamic radical so-called
who know scarcely anything about their
own Islamic theology suicide bombers and
the like many Western liberal agnostics
interestingly are keen to point out that
gap in the case of Islam
keen to point out the gap between as it
were the theology of Islam of a religion
of compassion and justice and the
grotesque distortion of that by Islamic
terrorists but then by no means usually
so keen to point to the gap between the
gospel and actually existing
Christianity on the whole they will
prefer rather more sloppily to take
actually existing Christianity as the
norm it's also true of course that a
great many Christians have fallen play
prey to flagrantly ideological versions
of the gospel that's to say versions of
it which in one way or another play into
the hands of what some John honestly
ominously refers to as the powers of
this world as far as I can see there is
no support in Scripture what I made I
believe may still be the practice at the
Mormons Brigham Young University I
refrain from placing that last word in
scare quotes
we're certainly when I was was lecturing
there there are a miserable time in my
life those students or faculty members
who needed for medical reasons to grow
beards were required to carry on their
persons a so-called beard card but
perhaps I've overlooked some anti
shaving verse in Luke or Matthew and
regards it's not in fact the case
however that even given the inevitable
gap not only in in terms of theology but
in terms of any academic discipline
between the sophisticated understanding
of the more popular one but not the case
even so that this understanding of the
gospel is confined to an intellectual
elite my own father who left school the
age of 15 to work for almost the whole
of his life in a factory who probably
never read a book in his life that's why
I know what I sure have endorsed it as a
good Roman Catholic similarly those on
the political left who regard socialism
as more for the matter of just labor
camps and mass murder and state tyranny
are not simply a coterie who happened to
be familiar with the intricacies of the
Granero sir
on the contrary hundreds of thousands of
rank-and-file of men and women in the
working-class movement have rejected
such a caricature caricatures which in
fact ironically often come from
intellectual elites or coteries
themselves for some more authentic
interpretation of socialism there's no
reason I think to think anything
different of the Christian movement in
any case you don't settle the question
of whether say the New Testament is on
the side of the rich and powerful by
appealing to what most people happen to
believe anymore than you verify the
second law of thermodynamics by popular
acclaim you simply have to argue the
question on the basis of what evidence
you have and what rational techniques
you can summon those who dismiss what I
would see as soundly based readings of
the gospel because they're not all
widely shared among Christians a rather
like those who object to some soundly
doctrines of liberalism simply because a
lot of ordinary men and women believe in
electrocuting rapists and shipping
immigrants back to where they came from
does that then discredit the sound views
of liberal rationalists politically
speaking like Christopher Hitchens I
think not but not all people believe in
electrocuting rapists or shipping
immigrants where they where they came
from people who say things as they
sometimes do back in England like it
would be a funny world if we all thought
the same or it takes all kinds to make a
world a saying which Ludwick Stein as
non Englishman Klaus was very struck by
and thought it was a most beautiful and
kindly saying Wittgenstein said it takes
all kinds to make a world people who say
that kind of thing may not be all that
well versed in John Locke or John Stuart
Mill but that doesn't mean that they're
fascists beasts either or that their
liberalism which all those sentiments
are of course is not genuine besides if
religion has so flagrantly failed to
live up to its own founding principles
what about liberal rationalism what of
the middle-class liberal or
enlightenment lineages which ditch
khun's so zealously champions have these
not themselves been from time to time a
little less than perfect in their
fidelity to their own admirable
doctrines what of the violent
subordinates the boiling of freedom and
democracy of liberal capitalist society
the generation of poverty and famine the
warfare of sublime proportions the
arming and championing of one Oh Diaz
tyrant after another
well wonders why many of those Western
commentators like Martin Amis
who responded to Islamic terror with
panic and hysteria didn't find their
liberal sensibilities quite so wounded
by the crimes of their own civilization
or at least didn't speak out quite so
vociferous Lee
about them why was it only after 9/11 I
wonder when they themselves were now for
the first time potential victims of
attack with no thin line of soldiers
between them and the enemy that their
moral indignation broke cover so
stridently what human carnage terrorism
has so far murderously brought in the
West is a pinprick compared to the
frightful history of slaughter and
oppression of the West itself emitted
Lee we don't know what the future might
hold
in this respect as far as terrorism goes
but it's quite as probable shortly that
we shall be done in by our own into nice
side quarrels as that we shall be done
for by the new narrative of terrorism
those who belong to civilizations like
our own which have long Harris
undermined and sometimes destroyed the
way of life of others but have not been
remarkable for their loud public
protestations against the fact are now
clamoring loudly because their own way
of life is for the first time under
military assault and under assault
ironically partly on account of the way
it has treated others it's not an
edifying spectacle in any case isn't it
from right-wing Western ideology that so
much radical Islamist ideology Springs
ditch khun's and his ilk but support by
and large the political status quo with
various degrees of reformist dissent
indeed Richard Dawkins is raucous
assaults on religion a case of
evangelical atheism if ever there was
one are in marked contrast with the
sedate North Oxford ISM of his general
political outlook Dawkins dislikes what
has flowed from Abraham for some
excellent reasons I think but he also
finds it repugnant I think for much the
same reasons that one can imagine him
harboring stoutly anglo-saxon objections
to Lacombe situationism Trotsky Dadaism
the unconscious
Julia Kristeva Irish republicanism and
allowing one's children to run naked
around the garden smoking dope even so
it's perfectly proper and entirely self
consistent for a liberal like Dawkins
and I applaud him in this to oppose neo
liberalism he's a stout an excellent
critic of United States foreign policy
for example just as one can be a fan of
the New Testament but not of the Vatican
but he doesn't concede that in that case
he doesn't concede the contradiction in
his own case as it were to his opponents
ditch kids rightly upholds liberal
values while rightly rejecting quite a
few aspects of actually existing
liberalism but he won't extend that
position and neither will his more
bibulous half Christopher Hitchens to
Christianity
neither is in much of a position then to
call the religious kettle black
Hitchens we can confidently assume
doesn't recognize his beloved Jefferson
in Guantanamo Bay however pally he may
be with some of the architects of that
hellhole
it's just that neither of them engages
in the same capacity to think both sides
of the question simultaneously which is
by no means the same as being impeccably
even-handed when it comes to religion
it's here that the liberal rationalism
which motivates their hostility to
religion and in many cases rightly and
excellently so suddenly deserts them the
same discrepancy of course between
principle and actuality goes I hardly
need sane for the political left which
has scarcely been a stranger in its own
camp to the gap between noble ideas and
their unsavory incarnation Marxism began
among other things as a response to a
Christian movement which had betrayed
its roots and ended up doing much the
same thing it's just I think that for
the deepest understanding of how and why
that happened the most historically
based wide-ranging ethically
Amity rebased founded account of how
that happened to Marxism one has to go
to certain mainstream currents of
Marxism to understanding liberal
humanism just isn't radical enough the
purpose in the same way the disgusting
betrayals of the Christian churches
stand under the judgement of the gospel
itself the story of liberal
enlightenment is one of an exhilarating
emancipation which constitutes a legacy
beyond price nobody was more tenaciously
of this opinion and Karl Marx you can
tell a Marxist were postmodernist in the
Marxists undying admiration for the
middle class he remembers of course was
means day its heyday the most
revolutionary formation which history
has ever witnessed wiping the last trace
of the also regime from the face of the
earth except for the Duke of Edinburgh
the values of that liberal enlightenment
of that bourgeois enlightenment of which
Marx was so enamored and of which he
quite rightly saw himself as the heir
without which he thought any socialism
would perish are to be defended the
values that are surely to be defended
both against the pretentious follies of
post-modernism and in real life
protected by all legitimate force if
necessary
from those high-minded unenlightened
fanatics who seek to blow the heads of
small children in the name of Allah some
on the political left I think
scandalously have muted their criticism
of such atrocities of such Islamist
atrocities in their zeal to point the
finger of blame at their own rulers and
should be brought to book I think for
this hypocrisy the Enlightenment stemmed
of course in part at least from
Christian values but also saw actually
existing religion as part of the
barbarism and despotism but it was out
to oppose even so in a devastating irony
it inherits its brave campaign against
superstition partly from Christianity
itself with its rejection of all
false gods and prophets all idols
fetishes magic rituals and powers of
darkness in the name of human flesh and
blood it goes without saying that we owe
to bourgeois enlightenment the Civil
Liberties freedom of thought feminism
socialism and many aspects of democracy
and republicanism which we cherish most
deeply and with that of course
nichkhun's would thoroughly agree but he
wouldn't agree with this but at the same
time such enlightened liberal humanism
has been the legitimating ideology or at
least a certain very dominant not the
only but a very dominant legitimating
ideology of a capitalist and imperialist
history more steeped in blood than any
other episode in history this is what
Dickens doesn't say about a pible
liberal enlightenment only Marxism to my
knowledge recounts the story of how
these two contrasting narratives are
secretly one the minds as both of the
precious achievements of say Francis
Bacon and of the fact that he was devout
believer in torture that liberal of
modernity means both contraception and
Hiroshima liberal liberation movements
and nuclear warfare some people think it
Eurocentric to point out that Europe was
the historical home of modernity
forgetful that this means among other
things that it was the home of the
Holocaust the radical answer to the
question of whether modernity
enlightenment his progressive is surely
an emphatic yes and no
and one of the best reasons in my view
for being a Marxist apart from the
agreeable exasperation it causes to
people who don't like is that no other
body of doctrine of which I'm aware
asserts that liberal enlightenment of
the dove the Dickens variety is at one
and the same time a tale of an
enthralling advance in human
emancipation and one long insupportable
nightmare from which no doubt we are
struggling to awaken the latter tale
moreover as the verso - the others recto
let us say the two colliding histories
two conflicting histories structurally
complicit structurally cheap but not
just contingently cheek-by-jowl not just
a kind of conventional liberal well on
the one hand and on the other hand but
actually sides of the same narrative
it's thus that being a Marxist allows
one as it were to speak out of both
sides of one's mouth simultaneously
yielding no comfort on the one hand to
the elegiac gloom of those enemies of
enlightenment with a patrician or
postmodern
for whom it would seem the invention of
everything from combine harvesters and
dental anesthetics to feminism and anti
colonial independence was a ghastly
mistake all part of some illusory
narrative of progress while on the other
hand refusing that progressive fist you
foria of which talking's a spiritual
child of HG Wells and CP snow is a
resplendent and example which for which
apart from the stubbornly lingering spot
of barbarism here and there history as a
whole is steadily on the way up if ever
there was a pious myth and a piece of
credulous superstition it's the liberal
rationalist belief that you know a few
hiccups apart where were all steadily on
our way to a far finer world my ex Prime
Minister who I believe will be among you
fairly soon
is a shining example of that kind of
credulous nonsense this foolish
triumphalism is so to speak a hangover
from the heroic liberal heritage when
the bourgeoisie had quite good reason to
believe that because it was historically
and politically on the way up but one
now existing in Congress Lee
cheek-by-jowl with the cynicism
skepticism or nihilism into which much
of that honorable liberal lineage has
now degenerated radicals are those who
believe that things are extremely bad
with us but they could feasibly be much
improved conservatives believe that
things are pretty bad but that's just
the way the human animal is and liberals
believe that there's a little bit of
good and bad in all of us
now Marxism has no quarrel with with the
mighty ideals of liberal enlightenment
it doesn't really have any ideals of its
own other than this it simply simply
inquires with a certain foe naive T
perhaps why whenever there's an attempt
to realize these ideals they tend by
some inexorable logic to twist into
their opposites so that freedom for some
becomes oppression for others notional
equality generates actual inequality and
so on by what mechanisms does that
happen is the persistent question that
Marxism addresses to capitalism reason
as a form of Dominion has produced some
of the very aspects of Western
civilization to which is lat Islamism
Islamic radicalism is a pathological
reaction in this sense civilization and
barbarism enlightenment and
irrationalism are by no means the simple
opposites they may appear what was long
ago named the dialectic of enlightenment
is you might say a kind of a form of
constructive doublethink
which the traditional name is
dialectical I suppose that Dawkins in
particular with his sanctimonious high
Victorian faith in scientific progress
has apparently failed to grasp I don't
mean that there's no such thing as
scientific progress of course or that
there's no such thing as progress of
course there's lots progress the more
the merrier but there's no such thing as
progress with a very large capital P and
that's where I think ideologically
speaking Dawkins goes wrong for liberal
rationalism by and large civilization
and barbarism or the opposition between
them can increasingly be mapped now on a
West East axis and I'll say more about
this in my final lecture this super
civilized brand of cultural supremacism
which would no doubt be much offended by
mere common or garden racism is now much
in fashion
in the West Martin Amis speaks of
Islamic society as I quote less evolved
than the West at a time when the West is
busy slaughtering hundreds of thousands
of the members of that society it's hard
to get less-evolved on that one can also
map the pair civilization and barbarism
vitally on a temporal axis first
barbarism then civilization the
synchrony of the two on which Marxist
like Val T Benjamin insists the fact
that human civilization for Freud as
well is among other much finer things a
higher or sublimated form of barbarism
in which the violence which originally
rested it from chaos has to be
maintained insiders and Outsiders that
synchrony of the two is therefore
disavowed for radicals barbarism of one
kind or another has remained one of the
secretly enabling conditions or barely
concealed concealed underside of that
precious thing we call civilization
whether in the West or in the East a
barbaric underbelly which with the help
of George Bush and his neocon gangsters
has recently become rather less
concealed and rather less ashamed
shamefaced a narrative which markers in
particular has to deliver is of how
Western capitalist rationality
perpetually breeds its own savage
irrational isms as a backlash without
the slightest need to resort to the
input of Islamic outsiders and there
like perhaps we should recall this fact
before we begin piously prating of
british or american values would i think
do no harm to ditch kim's is comically
intemperate philippic against religion
indeed evil considerably reinforced it
to approach the subject as the liberal
rationalist he is rather the subject has
it as he does to the kind of
indiscriminate condemnation which is
neither liberal
nor rational it would be greatly to the
benefit of Dickens's moral integrity and
intellectual honesty I think to
intersperse his mildly monomaniac
diatribes on the topic we're speaking
here of monotheism versus monomania
right with the odd glancing Ellucian i
mean even if you relegated it to some
Shai footnote you know nestling beneath
his text to say you know the work in
alleviating human suffering which
Christianity and other faiths have
carried out for centuries among the
wretched of the earth or its efforts in
the cause of global peace or the
readiness that some religious types have
shown to lay down their lives for others
all those clergy who have given their
lives as martyrs not least in Latin
America in the struggle against us
supported autocracies knowledge in all
this wouldn't necessarily mean for
dickens sustaining the fatal wound in
the ideology okay
many Western liberals are as I've said
before careful to distinguish their
criticisms of so-called Islamism from
criticisms of Islam itself they're
rarely so scrupulous however when it
comes to home based faiths like religion
it seems not to be the case that
liberalism begins at home I live in
Ireland and the Irish have been
shamefully abused and exploited by the
Roman Catholic Church in many tediously
familiar ways I won't go through them
but the way they are the Irish are
perhaps the least aware of the way
they've been exploited by the Catholic
Church is the fact that they've never
really been offered a version of the
Gospels which it took even the slightest
effort to reject for any you know
half-decent sensitive civilized person
so like a lot of people they've been
able to buy their atheism or agnosticism
on the cheap and this is a form of
deprivation against which one ought
properly I think to protest even if it's
a more subtle and less important form of
deprivation than being locked up for
life by psychopathically sadistic nuns
for having borne a child out of wedlock
the Catholic Church is in such
understandably unjustifiably bad odor in
Ireland today that people these days
sometimes cross the street when they
catch sight of a preach priest
approaching in the old days it used to
be a landlord yet the cruelties and
stupidities which the Irish Church has
perpetrated don't prevent me from
recalling how without it generations of
my own ancestors in Ireland would have
gone unschooled underst uncle sold and
unburied one of my own forebears in late
19th century Ireland father Mark
Eagleton got into hot water with his
bishop for denouncing the local landlord
from the pulpit I suppose that Dawkins
wouldn't take kindly to the case that
acquired political characteristics can
be genetically transmissible but this
does seem to be somewhat of an example
of it let's see how we do know okay I'll
try to finish off and I'll leave out
some boring stuff and it's curious isn't
it how the how avatars of liberal
enlightenment like Hitchens Dawkins
Martin Amis Salman Rushdie and Ian
Mattoon have much less to say these days
about the evils of global capitalism as
opposed to the evils of
call Islam indeed many of them hardly
mentioned the word capitalism at all one
doesn't hear them speaking out in loud
concert against for example the hideous
american-backed regimes in Saudi Arabia
or Pakistan as they did about Saddam
Hussein once the hunt for reprisals for
9/11 was on it's a familiar fact though
apparently not all that familiar to the
US media that 30 years to the day before
the attack on the Twin Towers the United
States government violently overthrew
the democratically elected government of
Chile installing in its place an odious
puppet autocrat who went on to Massacre
far more people that died in the World
Trade Center the United States also of
course supported for many years a regime
in Indonesia which probably murdered
more people than Saddam the same that
they didn't need their oil there's
reason to believe that Islamic terrorism
is among other causes shouting produced
is among other causes a reaction to this
Imperial history which is not claimed
that there will be not there were no
fanatical Islamists around without
Western imperialism just as there would
be doubtless fanatical Christian
evangelicals rather that for example
without that vast concentration camp
known as the Gaza Strip it is not out of
the question that the twin towers would
still be standing those like the
novelist Martin Amos who resent the
ascription of even this much rationality
to an Islamism which they prefer to see
simply as psychopathological should have
a word I think with those in the British
intelligence services whose task it was
some years ago to monitor the Irish
Republican Army these professional
anti-terrorists knew enough not to
swallow a lot of stupid tabloid hysteria
about terrorists as monsters and mad
beasts they were well aware
British intelligence was well aware and
is well aware that their IRAs behavior
however sometimes murderous was in a
narrow sense of the word rational and
that without acknowledging this fact
they would be incapable ever of
defeating it that was not in doubt in
the inner Karla's of the British
government a CIA as I said before with
its record of kidnapping torturing and
murdering its support for death squads
and suborning of democracy certainly
qualifies in my view as a terrorist
organization yet this doesn't mean for a
moment that its agents are in the least
irrational far from it the other side
but pathologizing ones enemy is
exculpating oneself I will however stop
there short as before I'm afraid and
just to leave time for discussion if you
like to raise any point